hello everyone and welcome to the 2018
World Chess Championship match between
Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano Caruana this
is Game two of the rapids Magnus Carlsen
has won Game one if you haven't seen it
I will put a link to it in the
description below was a very intense
game and this is a game - now Caruana
has the white pieces without further ado
I'm showing you these games as they are
being played so let's just check them
out I will color on a strike back with
the white pieces basically we will have
a repeat of a game over line that was
played every time in the classical time
format of course the engagement Dean of
Russell emo attack so Caruana opens
would be for of course he definitely
prepared something so let's see who
deviates first it will be cousin or
Caruana
c5 the Sicilian defense is on the board
Knight of three Knights to c6 b4 so
everything we've already seen in this
match captures captures Knight to f6
Knight c3 and E 5 the last curve
variation is on the board Knight d2 b5
we have D 6 and now Knight to d5
we've seen in every game in this line
Knight captures pawn captures and now
Knight to e7 this is the second time
Carlsen goes for this line at the last
time he played it was in game 12 so
let's see what goes on
c4 Khurana continues the same as he did
in the Classical time format 90 g6 and
Queen to a4 we have Bishop to d7 by
Carson and now Queen to b4 it'd be
interesting if Carson continued now
white is already threatening tonight
capture some distance but it would be
interesting because Crossing won Game
one of the rapid if he if he went
actually for the Bishop to a5 line
offering a perpetual like he did in the
Classical time format then we would have
Queen back to a4 Bishop d7 coming before
Bishop to a5 but of course he does not
go for it as Caruana most likely
prepared something for it so instead
Queen to b8 a new move we have in this
game and it's similar to the move
Houdini played a stock first played
against Houdini that Queen tabby a line
where the Queen will at some point to
return to c7 when the knight is kicked
away from b5h for our mana now once the
question Cousins questionable knight on
g6 and Carlson says h5 my knight is
perfectly fine Angie's
Bishop to e3 and now we have a new move
this position was never before reached
in any database so now both players are
presumably out of book a six kicking
away kuranes knife from B 593 and now
comes a five as at some point this night
might get any some ideas to come to a 4
and B 6 so Crossin has a different plan
with 8 5 kicking away Coronas Queen
Queen 2 B 3 and a 4 and now karana has
to decide what to do with the Queen B 4
is possible Queen B sixes are highly
questionable what would the Queen even
do there Brooke 2 ea6 can simply kick
you know push it back whenever it wants
so Queen to d1 by Caruana
Bishop to e7 we have G 3 a very
important move that we've already seen
in game 12 controlling the knight on g6
taking away DF 4 Square from it
Queen the c8 and now the Queen is no
longer necessary there the Queen Bishop
battery now takes control of the G 4
square and Caruana
reinforces that we have Bishop to e2 and
cousin goes the Bishop to g4 nonetheless
he wants to trade these two bishops and
weaken the c4 pawn rook to c1 karana
develops the rook and also and now the
rook will also protect the c4 pawn this
night might come to b5 at some point
Bishop captures Queen captures in Queen
to f5 now of course and finds a way to
infiltrate this position with the Queen
and he has a very devious plan
especially for such a such a rapid time
control he wants to play efore I move
that King as as a as a general theme in
in a lot of the Alliance of the roster
Lima played he wants to play E for this
night can then come to e5 and then
Knight to f3 will be a deadly maneuver
here we have c5 like Caruana he wants to
create a passed pawn Knight to b5 was
also an idea going to threatening
something like Knight to c7 but rook c8
and a black should be okay so instead we
have c5 by Caruana and here if cross and
went for this then corona can simply
capture it after Bishop captures Queen
b5 check you would have to block Queen
captures you would for a moment stall
with you no hindered blacks the
development black will not be able to
castle but after 97 castles castles it
would actually be
perfectly fine position for white world
white would have a very dangerous past
porn
so after c5 we have castles c6 by
Caruana
creating a past C pawn B captures D
captures on c6 and now rook after c8
Carlsen puts his rook in front of the
pass pawn as now this is a very
dangerous pass pawn but it's not at all
clear how Khurana plans to promote it
but after all this is a rapid game it's
nothing is too clear here as there is so
much at stake here here Queen to c4 a
very nice move by Caruana if he decided
to go he has to protect the the past e6
pawn if he goes for something like
Knight to d5 seems very nice the rook is
protecting the pond the night is
threatening the bishop on e7 but here
crossing would have the very unpleasant
Queen to e4 the knight on d5 is
undefended and also the rook on h1 is
undefended and after Knight captures
with Czech Knight captures the rook is
still under attack
you would have to castle but then white
loses the very strong passed pawn and
black is just better here
so after look after c8 karana plays the
correct move Queen C for defending the
c6 pawn bishop to d8 gaining more
control of the c7 square but also in
some variations if no Knight moves
Bishop to a5 check could be very
dangerous
we have Knights the d5 and now comes for
a very nice move by Carson and karana is
very long on time here he really has to
figure out what to do and it's not at
all a simple position for example if he
decides the castle here 95 wins on the
spot the queen is under attack the Queen
has no good squares from where she can
guard the knight on d5 and after you
move the Queen Knight of three check
King has to move you win the knight and
the game a move that would allow Caruana
to continue playing this game and
perhaps you know maybe play it further
would be Bishop to d4 because you would
actively defend against Bishop to a5
here after Bishop to a5 Bishop the C
tree blocking captures captures this
rook will come to a5 attack the knight
but then after the knight moves with an
attack on the Queen it will be possible
to defend here Caruana played c7 but c7
is simply a blunder
that core awana will simply not be able
to recover from cross simply Bishop
captures on c7 we have night captors on
c7 and yes corona has one upon here but
Carlson goes Knight to e5 with an attack
on the Queen and also with threats of
this Knight coming to f3 so it's not at
all clear how to defend this also the
night it can come to d3 with check pick
up the rookin c1 so in face of all of
these threats the different the best
course of action would be to simply
allow night to d3 so black can pick up
the rook here and then after that go
after the knight and c7 but that would
also be a losing the idea here corona
tried a different plan he played Knight
to d5 which is a very nice idea but here
karana was too far down on the clock and
the idea is next of course and actually
captures the Queen then you get 97 check
cross and moves the King Knight captures
on f7 and after captures captures the
Optus captures you can see that Caruana
would actually be up a whole night which
are most likely are winning the game but
here after Knight to d5 crossing simply
played King to h7 now there are no more
tricks with Knight to e7 and here
there's simply too much being threatened
that there's no way to defend the rook
and C One Nights 2 D 3 is coming nice to
f3 a huge threat and here in line of
simply too much too much threats there's
really nothing to do here one one such
idea would be if let's say you move the
Queen Queen e2 and now comes Knight d3
check with a double attack against the
rook King moves simply Knight captures
on c1 and now it's it's it's simply too
much to bear
after the knight moves for example the
Queen and f5 is attack the rule can see
it is attacked Queen moves now comes
Queen to d1 but now Queen will capture
the knight on e7 you would not or you
can go for this but then the Queen hangs
on e2 so basically heater is fine Queen
moves Queen captures and now there's
really nothing to do Bishop captures
Queen goes back to e5 and it is possible
to continue but your development is just
terrible you have
you're down the exchange and you will
lose this game eventually but one
problem other than all of this after
King 2h7 Caruana spent all of his time
he had less than a minute on the clock
and in this position he decided to
resign the game so this is Game two of
the rapid I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank James Lindsay Zane
Hooper Jason Taylor ego and civic and
given manage for a contribution to my
channel thank you what I really
appreciate it now cross and is in the
lead two points in the match and as
there are two more games left in the
rapid time format Caruana now has to win
both games to get back in the match will
he still have his super nurse and
perhaps even try to complete this
Herculean task we'll just have to check
it out so that's the game III do hope
you enjoyed it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
with Game three of the Rapids see you
soon